we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
depressing voicemail related to the
midterm elections this week take a
listen well once again it's been proven
evil wins out over good except in the
movies and on TV if he was willing to
cheat and lie and steal and manipulate
and good it's not willing to do those
things evil always wins yeah
so i share the depression that you are
experiencing because it didn't go as
well as we wanted but I am actually I
feel like I'm being realistic when I say
the Senate was stacked against us and we
didn't lose that much doesn't really
change the balance cuz they controlled
it anyway taking over the house is good
I will never be upset if my side doesn't
do voter suppression just because
they're doing it I will not be critical
of my side for not using deliberately
bad faith and toxic arguments but where
I agree is that the left needs to
understand how it is that the right is
winning and how to fight against it
because if we don't we will get crushed
in 2020 so I believe that this is the
beginning I am now working on 2020 I
want you joining me in doing that that's
why I'm calling for people to sign up
for memberships and make contributions
the media determines the narratives on
so many of these issues that end up at
the deciding election so if you want to
make an investment in the election going
the way you want you have to make an
investment in media that represents your
values and doesn't stoop to the level
that they are willing to stoop to we've
got a great bonus show today we will
talk about so many things including the
latest with the studio and much much
more thanks to everybody for watching
the two-year countdown starts now